a dude uh screamed to me the other night
hey will i want to be an actor man i
want to be an actor just like you you
know usually people say stuff to me like
that i'm like yeah man you know you do
is give them an encouraging word
but i was just sitting here thinking and
it dawned on me 99
of people that say stuff like that are
not willing to do what it takes to make
their dreams come true the marines have
a saying everybody wants to go to heaven
but nobody wants to die
and that's just real at the center of
bringing any dream into fruition is
self-discipline
you know some something as simple as
food and eating
it's not about your your body as much as
it is about your mind it's getting
command of your mind to be able to
choose actions that are in your own best
interest every day
we are choosing that's not in our own
best interest right so if the world is
attacking you and the world wants to
fight you and the world's trying to hold
you down so you're going to kick
yourself in the balls
so you don't stop yourself from getting
what you dream
self-discipline is the center of all
material success you cannot win the war
against the world
if you can't win the war against your
own mind i know that most people who are
blessed with so much talent
great parents great upbringing didn't
count where i come from
they're gonna quit before me
having all the tools that they have
they didn't have the ability to examine
themselves
when you have everything so nice in life
it's great to have a great life
but what happens is you don't
self-examine
you don't do a live autopsy
when you have a [ __ ] up life
[Music]
it almost forces you to do a live
autopsy it forces you to find strength
from places that no one looks from
because food is not at the ready
you know your me i have a learning
disability it's not at the ready i can't
just pick up a book and start reading
right right there's preparation behind
everything i do
there's there's everything i do has to
come with so much preparation it's
despicable it makes me sick my own
personal life makes me sick that's why
i'm so disciplined now without my
self-discipline there is no david
guidance
like i can't like stop reading
i won't be able to read tomorrow
it will i will lose it that fast wow
yeah you know i you know i cannot stop
going to the gym
my mind is set up in a spot where hey
the second i stop it wants to stop
because i had a quitting mind growing up
when you get beat to shot you all the
time your mind wants to go to that nice
spot where you're comforted
where you're not trying where is easy
that's where your mind it doesn't want
to think
you have all these things in the mind
and the mind can only absorb so much
so all the pain that has to go through
it doesn't it wants to push it away it
says let's not do that
so every day i'm fighting where the mind
wants to go
so it's a it's a it's a constant it's a
constant evolution man
i'm i've never arrived
i've never i'm i'm kind of right now i'm
stressing out two three hours a day
every i'm trying to reinvent the wheel
i'm like oh man i went through navy seal
training being done
i ran over seven thousand miles in 2007
being [ __ ] up i did pull up records
being [ __ ] up
now
that the mind is so strong let the body
catch the mind so that's now where i'm
at so i'm always trying to reinvent the
wheel and see what i'm capable of next
one of the things that i think you
should always come back to
first is take a look at how you set your
day up because how you set it up is how
it ends up how do i set my day up so
that i'm practicing what i call simple
discipline simple discipline is nothing
more than making and keeping simple
promises to yourself repeating it every
day the way that you start to change the
big things is you change the small
things make tiny teeny teeny promises to
yourself and then keep them so how do
you build simple discipline here are
some core skills that i do every morning
that have helped me number one
i do not sleep with the phone number two
when the alarm goes off on my phone it's
not near me so i have to get my ass out
of bed i get up i make my bed i get
moving
i get my exercise clothes on i move my
body i then journal i take 10 minutes to
myself to plan my day when i do that my
day is incredible i believe that how you
start your day dictates how the day goes
you should not just adopt somebody
else's morning routine and expect it to
work for you you need to customize this
you are unique i think about how do you
come alive for yourself in the morning
what are the five senses what's the
first thing that you see when you wake
up for me it's a painting that i
manifested out of thin air it reminds me
that what you put your mind to and what
you work toward
it will become a reality i always light
incense because it makes my senses and
my nose come alive i'm super mindful
over what i taste first thing in the
morning my grandma always had vinegar in
the morning with honey and hot water i
picked the one thing that matters to me
today you must know your outcome
how can you possibly be focused or
disciplined if you don't know the
outcome you're after
most people don't lack focus or
discipline
they lack clarity that would give them
the focus and the discipline
that's why the first high performance
habits is seek clarity we learned it
from our research right
well an outcome what am i after here
what's the goal
what's the tangible
or intangible thing that i know when i
get there
when i see that feel that experience
that achieve that
that's what i'm after here
that some kind of outcome you won't stay
disciplined unless you can see feel
sense
acknowledge intellectually what the
outcome is we're after
if you're not disciplined on a
consistent basis it's because you don't
know what you want
so don't beat yourself up that you're
lazy
you just need to make a decision
you need to make a decision about what
it is that you want and it doesn't have
to be what you want for your whole life
your ultimate grand purpose and the
cosmos of the destiny of universe no no
what do you want by friday
what do you want by the end of the month
what do you want this quarter
it's it's like start there
if you're really confused about the next
five years of your life please start
with the next five weeks of your life
come on
you people don't understand clarity
is built upon
you don't have the epiphany where
everything is perfect very few people
ever have a complete perfect picture
epiphany moment of everything coming
together in life very few people very
few people
instead usually what happens is as we
move throughout our lives we get a
little more clarity what we like and
what we don't like what draws passion
and strength and contribution what
doesn't
know your outcome you want this one know
your outcomes
number two
schedule
there is no discipline without a
schedule
it's so easy if your calendar doesn't
have anything in it the next six weeks
don't be mad at yourself for lacking
discipline no one shows up on lego it's
discipline day
and has nothing to do
discipline requires the schedule so fill
out your schedule work the schedule
fill out the schedule work the schedule
fill out the schedule works as you fill
out your schedule and you work the
schedule
you get more self-trust with that
self-trust comes confidence from that
confidence comes more competence we gain
more mastery and we're in the game more
we feel good about ourselves the
progress mind loves it eats it up it's
like hey we're doing it we said we were
gonna do it we did it we moved towards
our outcome today with a schedule what
an idea we kind of have this idea that
while you're free as a child and then
you
let me see if i can if i can put this
properly
that you have a certain delightful
wonderful positive freedom as a child
and then that's given up as you approach
adulthood but the truth of the matter is
is that
you have a lot of potential as a child
but none of that is capable of
manifesting itself as freedom before you
become disciplined
and discipline is a matter of the
imposition of order and the order is
necessary especially for people who are
hopeless and nihilistic
and lots of people are hopeless and
nihilistic
way more people than you think and part
of that is because no one's ever really
encouraged them and so the book is in
part a matter of encouragement it's like
lay yourself lay a disciplinary
structure on yourself get the chaos in
in in check and then you can move
towards a state that's freer because
it's disciplined first like look if
you're going to become a concert pianist
there's going to be several thousand
hours of extraordinarily disciplined
practice that's the imposition of order
on your potential let's say but what
comes out of that is a much grander
freedom and so in virtually every
freedom that you have in life that's
true freedom is purchased at the price
of discipline these thoughts that we
have we think there are thoughts so it
makes it really hard to change them and
people meditate try to not think
thoughts
show me some of your thumbnails
successfully consistently if they're
full
okay everybody the mind thinks thoughts
but here's the distinction
if i told you a hundred years ago we're
gonna fly to the moon and back you would
call me a lunatic that's where the term
comes from and people still use it and
it doesn't make any sense because the
lunatic is somebody thought we go to the
moon and back we've done it right
i didn't know that yeah that's where it
comes from that's where it comes from
but if i would have told you 100 years
ago
that there's going to be a box in your
pocket and you're going to pull this
thing out you're going to hit a couple
buttons and then it's going to capture
invisible waves that are drifting around
the earth and bring the waves in and
you're going to see somebody on the
other side of the earth and you're going
to talk to them
you're totally nuts
thoughts are those invisible waves
and when you use your body in a certain
way if i sit like this i'm going to
channel i'm going to tap into a
different channel of those waves than if
i'm sitting like this
kind of like a tv set if i turn one
channel it might be a comedy channel i'm
gonna see a lot of laughter turn another
one it's horror channel turn another
channel it's a romance channel
this is what changes which of those
waves you touch in so if you can start
to realize that your thoughts do you
think are your thoughts
there's nothing unique about your
thoughts they've been around for
thousands of years you're just tapping
into them because of what you're doing
with your body that makes you either
fearful or passionate or courageous or
whatever you're feeling
as you go in those states you get
different thoughts so what i want people
to see is they learn how to just see
those thoughts go by learn how to be
entertained by those thoughts because i
have crazy thoughts and but what i've
gotten good at is going look at that
crazy thought that's not me that's the
mind
not your mind because if it's you how do
you change you pretty hard but
i really truly know there's i haven't
heard a thought come out of you that's
original
you call them your thoughts but they're
not you've stolen them name it around
forever
when you see that it's easier to let go
of them and letting go of those thoughts
is one of the ways that you free
yourself and then again the more you do
it just like a muscle you get better and
better and better and all of a sudden
they used to make you crazy or stressed
out and like how many things have you
worried about that never came to be and
some people their life is good so they
worry about other people you know so
they're never not worried right so it's
really just a pattern if you want wealth
real wealth is not just money it's
emotion
it's like what are we really after in
money you don't want money you want
pieces of paper with the pictures the
deceased notables on it you want what
you think money will give you think
it'll give you freedom or security or
stability or love it won't give you love
it'll get you sex it won't get you a lot
of money won't right so
really what you're after is the emotion
and so what i want people to get is the
emotion they want now and all it is is a
new habit it's learning to discipline
this mind
right by realizing the mind thoughts are
out there
and letting them float by and constantly
coming back to what can i love about
this what can i appreciate it's like if
you can learn to love or at least
appreciate
start to enjoy
the things that you used to get upset
about
how much freedom would you have how much
more joy you'd have and i know people
got billions of dollars i've coached
them who's like holy they live in
scarcity all the time one man i'll never
forget he's screaming at his wife i'm in
the media i mean i'm in the house and
he's screaming at his wife because she
spent some money on a bunch of outfits
and stuff like that he's a
multi-billionaire he couldn't spend all
his money in his lifetime and then he's
totally upset at his daughter's in her
20s who spent some money too and i'm
like i pulled him aside afterwards and i
said
what do you do this for
and what do you do it for and he's like
well it's just it's the principle thing
i said no the principle thing is do you
love these people and do you want them
to have an abundant life
when you have there's you don't have one
loss but you live like you're poor
you know and it's like i finally got
through to them but so many people
that's why i say money doesn't change
you
money magnifies who you are
so you want to expand the depth of who
you are and free yourself from suffering
by just knowing it's a pattern of
thought and you can change the pattern
of thought if you study
people who are at the pinnacle of
anything
you recognize that to get there
motivation was maybe one percent of the
formula maybe
one percent
i'll prove it to you
if you want to become a world-class
bodybuilder say an ifbb pro
what that takes is you have to train
twice a day
six days a week
you have to have eight meals a day
your calorie intake is regimented your
meals are pre-planned and pre-cooked
you don't eat according to taste you eat
according to function
so my trainer for instance will eat and
i'm going what are you eating
and he's having the most he'll have
chicken that was boiled without salt
and he'll have like half a kilo of it
what are you doing
he says i'm taking in protein he doesn't
say i'm eating he says i'm taking in
protein for him it's functional it's not
taste based
then
you will probably have to train for a
minimum and this is if you are a genetic
phenom
you'd have to train for a minimum of 10
years
before you could get on a stage
and compete at an average level with an
average global bodybuilder average
okay
so why am i say why am i telling you
this
all all of us here at the beginning of a
new year write these things called new
year's resolutions
and then it you you know you new year's
resolutions number one make more money
yeah
uh number two uh
change my boyfriend
number three get into shape
yeah number three
get into shape is somewhere in the top
three
so what do you do you go to the gym you
get a gym membership
yep
you buy
you go to the local nike store and you
buy like all of your gym gear
you are motivated you are inspired you
are going to the damn gym
you go to youtube you subscribe to all
of the fitness channels you go to
instagram you follow all of the fitness
models you are motivated you are going
to the damn gym you're going to get in
shape
that's what you're going to do
the people you're following on youtube
have been working on for a minimum of
five years to look like that
so you have the incorrect understanding
that after a month of working out you're
going to look like them
so what happens in the first month
you're excited you go to gym every
single month
you know and you take the pains and your
body is sore but you know i'm excited
i'm going to gym then life happens
company doesn't make money you don't
make your targets you fall a bit ill
something happens and all of a sudden
you stop going to gym for a day a day
becomes two two becomes a week now all
of a sudden you've had a gym membership
for three months and you haven't been in
that time
what did you miss you thought motivation
was the formula winners don't need
motivation winners need discipline
discipline's about getting it done
because it needs to get done not because
i feel like it
not because i'm motivated for it
do you think nelson mandela is motivated
to spend 27 years in prison
do you think martin luther king was
motivated to march across the states and
proclaim freedom
do you think you know if you look at
people to change the world they're not
doing it because they're motivated
they're doing it because they made a
commitment to do it and they disciplined
to see it through
discipline is far more important than
motivation which is why you got to be
careful the decisions you make because
once you make the decision you have to
see that decision through
like my mentor says first we make the
decisions then the decisions make us
so you gotta be very careful the
decisions you make be very careful the
commitments you make
motivation i'm telling you now is
completely overrated
it's important don't get me wrong
you know we meet according to motivation
we feel good rara
but that'll fade
you need a stronger will and a deeper
commitment to see things through
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to learn how
to develop the discipline in your life
that you need check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there none of us none of us can afford
to have a life that is controlled by
someone else or a life that is basically
controlled by our emotions
i've learned